>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> GUHA SHANKAR: Hello.
Good afternoon.
Welcome to the third
and final program
in the Native American
Heritage Month Programs here
at the Library of Congress.
I'm Guha Shankar from the
American Folklife Center.
I've been working with
colleagues in the Office
of Equal Employment Opportunity.
Roberta Salazar also Eric Eldridge,
Carla David Catro [assumed
spelling] from the Law Library.
Jennifer in the back from CRS.
In order to do a series of programs
here at the library for this month.
It gives me great pleasure to
introduce Gabriela Pérez Báez,
the curator of linguistics
the Museum of Natural History
at the Smithsonian Institution.
I won't, obviously if I were
to sit here and read out all
of her accomplishments, that
would take up half the time.
So. I'm going to keep it
brief and just let you know
that Gabriela Pérez Báez
has conducted research
on Zapotec languages since 2002.
She's devoted much of her
work to studying factors
of language maintenance and
endangerment with a focus
on the impact of migration.
In the community of diasporic
speakers of [foreign words]
and the influences on its sort
of sister mirror community
in Los Angeles.
Importantly for the Library of
Congress, Gabriela is the co-PI
of the Breath of Life Languages two
about which she'll
be speaking today.
And it's important to the Library
because the Library of Congress,
and principally The American
Folklife Center, but also colleagues
in the Manuscripts Division,
represented by Barbara Bear
[assumed spelling] and Julia Miller,
along with colleagues in the
geography and maps division,
as well as the Prints and
Photographs Division host some
of these community members
who come and do research
in the National Library Collections
as part of their own programs
of linguistic maintenance, cultural
revitalization, and other purposes
for which they use the
collections here at the library.
So, it's been a very fruitful
collaboration for the last few years
and Gabrielle will talk
about that as well.
And speaking of collaborations,
one of our other principles
in this enterprise is Judith
Grey, head of reference
at the American Folklife Center
who's trying to walk in the door,
I'm not sure what she's
doing [laughter].
Thank you, Judy.
Come on in Judy.
So, after all of that, I will
now turn it over to Gabriella.
We will have about probably
25 minutes of presentation
and then we'll have;
30, who's keeping count.
And that will mean
there will be ample room
for questions and answers
at the end.
And please do make sure
that you do ask questions.
This is an interactive session.
We appreciate all of you
coming on your lunch hour.
And without further ado let me turn
it over to Gabriela Pérez Báez.
[ Applause ]
>> GABRIELA PÉREZ BÁEZ: Thank
you very much for that introduction.
It's a real pleasure to be here.
I was just telling Guha
that despite the fact
that we've been collaborating for
so long, because I'm always trying
to get things running for
Breath of Life at the Museum
of Natural History, I
don't get to be here.
So, this is a real treat.
So, I am currently serving as
director of Recovering Voices.
It's the initiative I
want to talk to you about.
And within that context,
I will talk specifically
about programmatic
activities like Breath of Life
and how they fit into our model.
So, Recovering Voices is a priority
interdisciplinary initiative
of the National Museum of Natural
History at the Smithsonian.
It's intended to respond to the
global loss of linguist diversity.
And not only that, it also focuses
heavily on the loss of knowledge
that is associated with the
loss of linguistic diversity.
The idea is to conduct and
enable research on languages
and knowledge systems, to understand
the loss of cultural diversity
and develop effective
responses to reverse it.
Access to collections is central
to the recovery in generation
of knowledge in the process.
Global impact is achieved through
partnerships with communities
with academic institutions.
We favor an interdisciplinary
approach in recognition
of the holistic approaches
to knowledge
that indigenous communities have.
This initiative, Recovering Voices,
originated within the anthropology
department at the National Museum
of Natural History, but
it works with partners
across the Smithsonian,
you know partner units
as well as outside.
And again, our focus of today's talk
will be the partnership that we have
with the Library of Congress.
What distinctive competence
do we offer?
Why should the Smithsonian
get involved in trying
to address the issue of
language endangerment?
Well, it's our collections.
That's why collections-based
research is
such a strong focus
of Recovering Voices.
We hold 9000 linear
feet of manuscripts,
which I've been told
equals five times the height
of the Washington Monument.
Generally, when I make this
analogy outside Washington,
nobody knows what it means.
But you guys know.
We also have 144.5, I was told,
million items in our collections
that cover the spectrum
of the seven disciplines
at the National Museum
of Natural History.
So, there's anthropology, mineral
sciences, zoology, etcetera, botany.
So, the focus in very simple
terms is to use these collections
as stimuli to generate
or regenerate knowledge
and help revitalize languages.
There's three of us.
Three curators from
the National Museum
of Natural History
behind this initiative.
Myself, serving currently
as director
for another couple more
weeks, and then my colleague,
Gwen Isaac who you see at the front
of this photo will be taking over.
She, along with Joshua Bell
and myself have been the three
curators behind the initiative.
And we have two program assistants.
And we have fellows,
interns, contractors depending
on what activity, what
special projects we have.
We have collaborators across
the disciplines in the museum.
Again, collaborators across
the Smithsonian Institution.
Notably the National Museum of the
American Indian, and the center
for Folklife and Cultural Heritage.
And, we have a network of
partners, starting with the Library
of Congress, but also the Myaamia
Center, who is a critical partner
in Breath of Life, the UNESCO,
University of Hawaii and so on.
So, let's talk about the
Recovering Voices model.
So, again collections are
central and our focus is
to mobilize these collections to
foster community-based research
for language and knowledge
revitalization.
And by community-based research
what we mean is community-driven,
or community-directed, or research
that is for community benefit
and that is designed in close
collaboration with a community.
The model works for
collections-based research both
in the museum setting and
in the field and I will talk
about the two settings
and how that works.
Our research priorities are three.
We run a community research
program, which I'll talk about.
The National Breath of Life Archival
Institute for Indigenous Languages,
which for short I'll refer to it as
Breath of Life, and field research.
So, let's start with the
Community Research Program.
The Recovering Voices
has an operating fund
that allows us to fund this.
It's by community researchers.
Three different visits per
year, to come and carry
out research on our collections.
That is designed by the researchers.
These researchers don't
need to be affiliated
with an academic institution.
And they do not need to
have an academic background.
Provided they are involved in
their community's activities
to revitalize culture,
language, knowledge.
And are able to articulate a project
around a particularly
robust collection
of any kind in our museum.
We're able to fund.
Right now, we're in the process
of finalizing the selection
of the community research
visits for 2017.
So, it's an annual
competitive process.
We don't get a ton of applications,
but we do get about a dozen.
Which is probably enough,
because we're able to fund three
and that way we're able to
fund a higher percentage
of the applications.
The idea is that we have
$10,000 that we're able
to put towards covering the
travel expenses, lodging,
etcetera of these visits.
We have so far funded 17
research visits since 2012.
And I know you're not
supposed to put,
you know, heavy text slides here.
But I figured this would give
you a sense of the breadth
of community research that has been
conducted so far under this program.
We recently, I'll mention
for example,
the last, the one at the bottom.
A group of Waija researchers,
I'm sorry Waija chiefs
who are also conducting research
from the northern Amazon
region were here in September,
seems like a long time ago.
But they were here in September.
They were able to work out an
arrangement with a local researcher
so that they could extend
their visit for up to a month
because they were staying
at this person's home.
And so, they were able to be
here visiting the film archives
at the [inaudible] facility.
They were also, they visited
the entomology collecting,
the birds collecting,
the fish collection.
It was really interesting.
I was just telling
Guha a few minutes ago
that it was very revealing for the
collections managers to be talking
to people who know these
species so incredibly well.
One of the Waija chiefs had actually
help collect some of the fish
that are in our collections
nowadays.
And they were able to
engage in a conversation
about how climate change is
impacting some of these species.
So, it's very much a dialogue.
Sometimes we feel that we gain
more as collections managers,
as curators from this interaction.
But, of course all of these
communities are walking away
with the ability to utilize these
collections, again as stimuli
for generating, or
regenerating knowledge.
Now, let me talk about
National Breath of Life.
So, the National Breath
of Life is based in DC
because of the unparalleled
collections that we have here
across the institutions based
in the region, in the city.
Specifically, there's
three partner institutions,
the National Anthropological
Archives
at the National Museum
of Natural History.
The National Museum of the American
Indian, and the Library of Congress.
This is a program funded by the
National Science Foundation.
And therefore, we partner closely
with other institutions outside the
federal government system to be able
to receive or use these grants.
So, we have partnered
with Yale University twice
and now we have a very
strong partnership
with the Myaamia Center
at Miami University.
You might have heard from the
recent McArthur Fellowship Awards,
you might have heard about Darrell
Baldwin, who was the recipient
of one of these awards this year,
for his work in reclaiming
the Myaamia language.
This is a language that
used to be spoken in the 40s
and through the work of Darrell
Baldwin, in collaboration
with a linguist from UC
Berkeley, they were able
to reconstruct the grammar
phonology of the language based
on archival materials, many
of which are at the NAA.
And to make a very long, 30,
40-year long story short,
the community now has
speakers of the language
that have various degrees
of competence.
But in his home, Darrell
and his family carry
out the daily life in Myaamia.
So, they've been effectively
able to reclaim the language,
something which we thought was
not possible even 20 years ago.
So, it's following that model, the
relevance of archival materials
for languages that no longer have
speakers or have very few speakers,
or where knowledge has
been eroded significantly,
that Breath of Life is designed.
And the model was actually
developed based on a document
that was produced by a group
in Australia called the
Australian Institute for Aboriginal
and Torres Strait Icelander Studies.
Breath of Life is a program that
has very long names throughout the
entire process.
So, they had recognized
that archives were really valuable
resources, and wrote a document
to detail and model a method for
using them for revitalization.
That model was taken and
further developed by,
and here's another long name,
the Advocates for Indigenous
California Language Revival,
in partnership with UC Berkeley.
And we have been, now and
UC Berkeley the focus was
on California tribes only,
that no longer have
speakers of their languages.
In DC, because of the breadth of the
collections that are available here,
we can go beyond that
limited set of participants
to serve any communities primarily
in the US, but also Canada,
and we might be hosting
someone from Mexico this year.
Independently of whether they have
speakers of the language or not.
Generally, because of the
situation in North America,
we hold participants whose
languages have very few speakers,
or no speakers left.
But that's not always the case.
So, the structure of Breath
of Life, or the goal is
to familiarize participants with
the archives and provide them
with the skills to be able to
find materials on their languages.
We teach fundamentals in linguistics
so that they can begin to read
and interpret the materials.
And anyone who's ever looked
at a manuscript knows
that it's not very easy.
There are idiosyncrasies
in the documentation,
there's handwriting quirks,
and you need to interpret what's
a noun, what's a verb etcetera.
So, we provide fundamental, you
know basics to be able to do that.
And, we discuss and demonstrate ways
that the materials can be utilized
for language revitalization
and we always have people
like Darrell Baldwin
and other people
who have very similarly
long-standing projects
in revitalization that come
and share their experience.
So, again there are
three core elements.
Basic linguistics, archival
research and applied approaches.
So, Breath of Life, unlike Berkeley
and other Breath of Life models
that only last a week, the National
Breath of Life takes two weeks,
because again of the
amount of materials
that can be consulted here.
During that time, the
participants who are selected,
it's a real competitive
process as well.
This year we received
around 70 applications.
And we'll be able to
hose about 30 of them.
So, every language group,
and sometimes we get one single
individual, but generally we get two
or three people form
one language community
who come and work together.
And each language group will get
an academically trained linguist
assigned to work with them one
on one throughout the two weeks.
On our end, the curators,
the archivists,
the librarians will teach
the participants how
to navigate the catalogs.
Every institution has a
different type of catalog,
but overall the principles
of catalog research are
applicable across the board.
So, we try to make sure that
when the participants leave,
they can still come back to
the catalog and find stuff
that they might be interested in.
We, of course provide
access to the materials.
So, ahead of time we pull up
everything for this language
and that language, and the
participants are able to work
on the materials hands on.
And we also produce
archival quality materials.
We were just actually
talking about trying
to make a more concerted effort
to inform the Library of Congress
about the languages that will be
represented in the next Breath
of Life, which by the way happens
May 29th to June 9th in 2017.
And that way the participants
can leave
with archival surrogates
of their materials.
So, Breath of Life national model
has evolved over the last few years.
We're going to have again the fourth
iteration in May 2017 for two weeks.
To date, so if you look at the
number languages that we've had
over the year, 22 was really a
lot of languages; 14, 15 is more
or less the scope that is
manageable and we can attend
to everyone's needs more
effectively and efficiently.
So, by the end of 2017 institute
we will have served about 70
or so language communities.
Every time provide
digital surrogates,
providing instruction,
access to the materials.
Now, we're trying to evolve,
because you know yes we could
keep doing this every 2 years
if the NSF documenting endangered
languages program is willing
to continue to fund us.
But we see a need to
evolve in a couple of ways.
First of all, one thing we're
doing this year is we're doing an
assessment of the program
to make sure
that indeed participants leave
knowing that they can always go back
to the catalogs and they
know how to use them.
That's something we haven't
been able to measure easily
without a structure to do so.
A person dedicated to
following up, and so on.
So, we're going be doing that
assessment of the program,
not of the participants, but
of our program this year.
The other thing we are doing
also based on the experience,
of serving the experiences of these
researchers, is that we've come
to the realization that we're
asking these researchers to develop
in two weeks the ability to research
catalogs, the ability to carry
out linguistic analysis
and the ability
to develop an implied
linguistics and pedagogy,
or language teaching approach.
All of that in two weeks.
So, that's a tremendous demand on
these researchers and we're trying
to figure out how to facilitate at
least a part that we know how to do
as curators, and archivist,
and library scientist.
So, in collaboration
with Miami University,
we are taking this tool MIDA,
which is the Miami-Illinois
Digital Archives developed
by the Myaami tribe and apply
it, or make it available
to Breath of Life participants.
What this tool does is it allows
you to upload digital surrogates,
high-quality archival tips.
You're able to code the
type of document that it is,
transcribe the language material.
Translate it, gloss it, do whatever
level of analysis you need to do
and it also allows you to
output data from this analysis.
So, the Myaami tribe is using
it to develop a dictionary,
which they don't yet have.
But when I learned about this
tool, which was developed through
and NEH grant, I figured that we
could tweak it to make it available
to any community that is ready,
that has the human resources
and an interest to do that kind
of work on their own language.
So, we're planning to do a pilot
this summer during the Breath
of Life weeks to test it out,
we'll work with one community
that precisely had that experience.
We were able to digitize everything
on their language,
deliver it to them.
We thought, we were very proud and
then they were very overwhelmed.
So, now we're to work through
the materials with this tool
and see how we can make it usable
within the Breath of Life context.
Let me see how am I doing on time.
I think I can still spend a little
bit of time on field research.
Maybe I wanted to do this
because that's something
I really like to do.
So, many of us are out in the field.
The three curators behind
Recovering Voices have field sites
that we've been working
at for a very long time.
We have community relationships that
go back 15, 20 years and we work.
We have fellows, and interns,
and collaborators that are
out in the field regularly.
I want to tell you little
bit about one project
that I've been involved
in for many, many years.
Just to show you how
collections-based research,
how we conceive of
collections-based research based
on outside in the field.
We're not just tied to
the museum collections.
I'm going to talk about the
work that I've been doing
to document the lexicon of Diidxaza,
which is Zapotec language
spoken in the south of Mexico.
It's spoken by about 70,000
speakers, which sounds like a lot,
but in reality, of
the 22 municipalities
where the language is
spoken, only or two have kids
that are learning the language.
So, at this point, in the
community that I work the most,
the youngest speakers are
in their late 20s already.
So, in devising a dictionary
for this I came upon; so,
this is a dictionary with
well over 10,000 entries.
Now it's about 13,000.
About 1000 of those entries
were related to plants.
And I had crazy entries
like the one I have here.
Where a tree would be called
[foreign words], so different names.
They would give me different names
in Spanish for the for this one word
in Zapotec [foreign words].
And the descriptions I
had were all over the map.
It's you know sometimes I would
be told that the tree exfoliates,
sometimes it doesn't exfoliate.
Sometimes it has latex.
Sometimes it has sap.
Sometimes it has medicinal uses.
Sometimes it doesn't.
And that made me realize that the
documentation I had collected,
this was in 2010, was just not
going to give me the documentation
that would be adequate
for a dictionary.
So, because I was already at
the Museum of Natural History,
I start talking to botanists.
I ran a pilot in 2012
to try to figure out how
to conduct botanical research,
which is something I did not
learn in linguistics school.
And, to make a long story short,
we carried out a one-year
plant documentation project,
interdisciplinary looking
at documenting the plants
with two botanists in the project.
Documenting knowledge with
several knowledge bearers
from the community, taking
audio, taking photographs
by a professional photographer.
And in the end, we ended
up with a huge database
which we're tweaking, even today.
We did 92 field collection sights.
Lots of numbers that I
don't need to bore you with.
But we ended up with a collection; a
huge collection of botanical samples
like the one you can see there,
housed at the National Museum
of National History, at the
National Herbarium in Mexico,
and two herbaria in [inaudible],
in the state where the
community is located.
And we have over 5000 high-quality,
high resolution images
of the plants.
So, with that we were
able to clean things up.
And I learned that there's an
entire, sort of the equivalent
of a genus of [foreign word] trees.
And indeed, they have
very different properties
because they're very
different species.
They belong to different families.
So, they're going to look
different and behave differently.
And now, we have a clear
understanding of why these trees,
despite their very
different properties,
are all lumped into
this one category.
And it's the architecture of the
tree that brings them all together.
We did not realize that.
These photos are from
the very last day
of one year of being in the field.
So, now let me just go back here.
This is a collection that
did not exist before.
Botanists, when they go out to the
field, they come back with hundreds
of plant samples, but the knowledge
is not something they have the
bandwidth to document.
We were able to do that.
We were able to also
create resources
that are meaningful
to the community.
The audios, the photographs.
The entire collection
is accessible online
through the botany
department's website.
But also, there's a dedicated
website for the collection.
And we created educational
materials for children,
for schools that are being
disseminated free of charge.
And we also developed workshops
around the topics of language
and environmental conservation
for children
which have been a running
monthly for over two years.
We also had a community visit
funded through the project.
This was a project funded by
the Museum of Natural History.
So, you can see here, the gentleman
in the photo, in the bottom photo,
was our key knowledge bearer.
He took us to the hills
for a full year.
And at the top, there's another
gentleman with his hands like this.
He is a historian and writer from
the community who was here working
with me to write definitions
for the plants in Zapotec.
So, we wrote, we didn't
translate but wrote in tandem.
I wrote in Spanish and English
and he wrote the descriptions
in Zapotec.
So, again, a very robust
collections-based research
that is collaborative,
beneficial to the community
and that be done in the field.
So, just to summarize,
our research priorities.
National Breath of
Life is a top priority.
The community research program,
right now we're serving
three communities.
If we can serve six per year
we'll be very, very happy.
And collaborative field-based
research.
We of course, because of the
type of institution that we are.
We have a lot of dissemination
and our reach.
A lot of outreach in communities.
As I mentioned the work on the
plants led to workshops for children
that keep going even two years after
we finished the basic research.
And we're constantly doing
public outreach at the museum.
We organize events such as the
Mother Tongue Film Festival,
which will be taking place
around the February 21st,
which is Mother Tongue Day,
observed internationally.
So, keep an eye out for that.
And that's it.
I probably did; well, no 30 minutes.
So, I'm available for any questions.
[ Applause ]
[ Inaudible Audience Question ]
Yeah, so the question was whether
the [inaudible] community has
participated in any of our programs.
They haven't.
But Jesse [inaudible] is of
course very; her background
and her contributions
are very comparable
to those of Darrell Baldwin.
So, we follow her work closely
because it informs a great
deal of what we're doing.
Yes?
[ Inaudible Audience Question ]
So, the question is whether
across the tribes, there's support
and networking for the purposes
of language revitalization.
They answer is yes.
so, there's a couple of things.
Again, I think that Darrell
Baldwin's involvement in Breath
of Life is very much an attempt
to share the model that has worked
so well for his tribe and his
language and put it to the service
of other tribes that might
be doing similar work.
One tricky thing with
revitalization overall is
that there's no one-size-fits-all.
And what works with one
community might totally bomb
in another community.
So, Breath of Life is a very
effective way for the experience
of people doing revitalization
in language reclamation.
So, in the cases where there
are no longer speakers,
or the base of first language
speakers was lost at some point.
And share those experiences
so that other practitioners
of revitalization can adapt those
experiences to their own benefit.
National Breath of Life, actually
one of the main objectives
of the program is to allow
participants to become part
of a growing network of
revitalization practitioners.
That's one of those things that
are a little bit intangible.
It's difficult to measure.
But we know that over time, all of
these practitioners will be talking
to each other and learning
from each other.
And in Breath of Life
we take participants
with different backgrounds.
We might have someone coming
in who has been involved
in the revitalization program for
20 years, and we might have someone
who is just getting into it
because now they have a baby
and they want the baby
to speak the language.
And you know all the
experiences in between.
So, they're able to talk to each
other with observed conversations
when someone will say
well and I really want
to have a school in my community.
I don't know how to do it.
I'm really overwhelmed.
And that's a conversation at
the beginning of the two weeks.
And by the end of the two weeks,
the conversation is now I know
what I need to tell my tribe.
Now I know how to do it.
Now I know people who
have been doing it
and who are willing to advise me.
So, yeah, there's very
much a lot of communication
and we try to foster that as well.
Yeah?
[ Inaudible Audience Comment ]
Yeah, there was another
question here.
[ Inaudible Audience Question ]
So, you're asking whether in a case
like the Quechua whether they
would be able to benefit from some
of these programs that we're
running at Recovering Voices,
or from Breath of Life,
specifically?
[ Inaudible Audience Question ]
Okay, so this is where the one size.
No one-size-fits-all
comment comes into play.
There are, actually one thing that
we're doing within Recovery Voices,
which is a separate line
of you know research,
is to try to document revitalization
efforts around the world.
Because we know a great deal
about what's being done in the US,
in Canada, in Australia,
and New Zealand.
Hawaii's the US, but it's
slightly different context.
But, we don't know much about
what the situation is elsewhere,
and yet there's a lot
of revitalization happening
around the world.
The idea with this research is
to be able to kind of get a sense
of how people respond to
their needs and challenges
in a new revitalization process.
Every community that wants to do
revitalization faces the issue
of not having materials
to teach the language.
And something that is very curious
is that revitalization seems
to have moved away from a natural
transmission of the language
from parent to child,
or caregiver to child.
To a language teaching practice.
And the language teaching
requires ancillary materials
to support the work.
What my suggestion would
be in that particular case,
I mean Quechua has a lot of
support because there's been a lot
of linguistics, anthropology
research conducted
on the various languages.
So, it might just be a matter
of looking actually locally what
other communities have developed
in the way of resources, and
learn from those experiences.
It's a long process and
sometimes when you think,
well it's really only
the grandparents
that are speaking the language
and the kids need to learn it,
and by the time we write the
books we might have lost many
of the speakers.
And so, what might come in handy
in that case is the
master apprentice model.
Which is when a language
speaker gets paired
up with a language learner.
Generally, adults, but it could
work with children as well,
for the purposes of creating a
kind of and immersion environment
between these two people for the
purposes of speaking the language,
and having the person learn
the language independently
of whether there might be
materials to support that process.
And so, this model,
specifically, wants to go back
to the natural transmission of
language and the development
of an immersion environment.
So, it sounds like maybe
in this particular case,
there can be an effort
to develop materials,
but maybe a master apprentice
type of model would work.
One thing we did in La Ventosa
for those Zapotec language
that I've been working
on for the dictionary
and the plants documentation is
that, I mean I develop materials
as part of the project, but we also,
we were not going to write a grammar
and you know a this and a that.
So, really the workshops
are designed
to emphasize oral communication
between these knowledge
bearers and the children.
And when you work with
children it works like this.
I mean you have to provide the
child with sufficient input.
They need to be able to get well
over 20% of their day in Quechua
in order for them to have
sufficient input for their brain
to acquire the language and for the
child to develop into a competent,
especially confident speaker.
If they are not confident,
they're not going to speak.
So, if there can be a combination
on those elements, I think that,
based on what you just told
me maybe that can work.
Yeah?
[ Inaudible Audience Question ]
Is there an audio or video
component to the work?
Yes. Audio has been critical
for the longest time.
And that's why you know, projects
like the, or documentation
as far back as when wax cylinders
were the medium has been critical.
You can annotate as much as you
want, but you lose a lot of detail
if the documenter missed a slight
detail of the pronunciation,
then you already have
deficient documentation.
So, audio is really critical
and the audio needs to be done,
recorded at a very high quality.
So, yes. That's always an element.
We, in Breath of Life we very
much see the relevance of audio.
Actually, one of the key reasons
why the partnership with the Library
of Congress makes so much sense is
that you know the wax cylinders
were moved here some time ago,
and that's a tremendous
resource for these communities.
Just to give you an example, there
are songs that are recorded that,
for example, for me as a linguist
they don't seem very interesting,
because the vocabulary is limited.
Maybe the syntax will be
fairly simple and limited.
But the performance of the
song opens a domain of use
of the language, which ultimately
is what these communities need to do
in order to bring back
active use of the language.
So, audio is critical.
Now, video has now become a much
more accessible medium of recording.
And it allows for everything else.
I mean I'm always, I always
have my hands up in the air.
You know, the cultural elements
that dictate your body language,
your disposition provide a
great deal of information.
I mentioned that the
Waija chiefs that came
in September spent a fair amount
of time at the film archives.
There are films produced in their
community 50 years ago or so.
That they never saw.
The filmmakers never went
back to the communities
to share that work with them.
So, they were able to see it.
And granted there's no
audio to go with it.
But there was so much cultural
information in that video
that they were just ecstatic.
And we were able to give them copies
of the video finally to take back.
So, long way to say, yes [laughter].
Yes?
[ Inaudible Audience Question ]
Sure. Well, I mean again Breath of
Life is very much about outreach.
It's, you know a community member
that I'm never going to know
about because I'm working
in the south of Mexico.
But because we have this
programmatic activity, we you know,
put out the call and you
know people get to apply
that otherwise we wouldn't
be able to reach.
So, it is very much about outreach.
Now, the workshops that we designed
for the community is
entirely outreach.
And the material.
So, we curated in collaboration with
the knowledge bearers in La Ventosa,
we curated a selection of plants
that they felt were the
most representative,
or the most important to know about.
Because we documented, we
collected 1300 botanical samples.
Out of those, we documented 288
Zapotec names and so we brought
that down to a selection
of 54 Zapotec names
that were the most important and we
produced a, which I meant to bring
and I forgot this morning.
I'm very sorry.
But we produced these very big,
sturdy books that are
actually like fact cards.
So, you can distribute
them in the classroom
and you know they can get beat
up and so on and they'll last.
With information in
Zapotec first, then Spanish.
It has all the botanical
information.
You know, the family, genus types.
So, that these materials can be
appealing for the knowledge bearer
without scholar-ization to
the natural sciences teacher
in the academic environment.
And we can bridge the
cultural knowledge
and the academic approaches
for the purposes
of learning about the local plants.
Learning about the names.
Also, inviting people
to read in Zapotec.
This community has had a
writing system since the 50s,
but very few people
actually read and write.
So, you know my colleague
there in pink,
he's one of the most prolific
writers ever in this region,
but there are very few like him.
So, the orange booklets there are
literacy manuals that we produced.
That was the one kind of applied
linguistics, item that we produced
for the project to invite people
to, in an accessible manner
to start reading more
in their language.
So, that's all.
We also produced games, which
the child is actually holding.
It's like a Bingo card with plants.
So, it's all outreach.
You have to be very
strategic about how you do it.
You need to make sure that the
outreach happens independently
of whether you're present there.
And that's really not easy to do.
But I think that's one of the
challenges that we're most happy
about in terms of how we've
been able to meet that.
So, the same thing we can
do here in the museum.
We can do the whole thing,
packaged, so-to-speak in the field.
Yes?
[ Inaudible Audience Question ]
Okay, so amazing question.
So, the question is how do you deal
with the rich dialectology
of Zapotec languages.
So, the term Zapotec actually refers
to a family of languages as diverse
as the romance languages.
So, you know someone who
speaks [inaudible] La Ventosa
like this gentleman and the kid will
not be able to understand the person
who is from the central valleys
near the capital city of the state.
Different tonal systems,
different pronominal systems.
Just like Spanish, and
Portuguese, and Italian.
So, what do we do?
Actually, the approach,
and this is the Zapotec
and not necessarily the
approach of Recovering Voices.
The approach by Zapotec
is to document as many
of these language varieties
as we possibly can,
so that we can understand
the differences and so
that we can understand whether,
you know, how we can make decisions
about what materials to produce
for each of these communities.
And there's an army of linguists
at this point in Waija tending
to Zapotec languages,
and many other languages.
Mystic languages have the same
level of dialectal diversity.
But it's, you know, the
materials that I produced
in Zapotec can be used
across 22 communities
because of dialectal differences,
they do not impede
mutual intelligibility.
But it is very much the case
that from one town to the next,
the tonal system will be different.
So, it's a huge challenge.
You really need a lot
of customization
for a situation as diverse as that.
Yes?
[ Inaudible Audience Question ]
So, the question is can existing
materials from one language
or one community be used for another
language and another community.
That's very much the case.
Yes. And I would say that
definitely reclamation efforts
in the US are very much based
on that level of exchange.
And Guha was mentioning the
Wampanoag using the dictionary
developed by the Passamaquoddy
because they had documented words
that the Wampanoag no
longer had access to.
Similarly, for the Myaamia
language, they looked at Myaamia,
they looked at Peoria
and they looked
at other related languages
in a similar way.
The [inaudible] they're
always looking at all
of the [inaudible] language, well
not all of them, but a set of,
closely related [inaudible]
languages
because they can draw from.
And then they also share the
materials and the approaches.
So, you know again, there is no one
size that fits all the situations,
but the exchange and taking a little
bit of here and applying it there,
that's really how the communities
develop their approaches.
And it's a massive effort.
And I do know.
When I started studying
linguistics a really long time ago,
things looked pretty grim.
And they don't look grim anymore.
It's amazing how many people
are so incredibly devoted
to restoring their cultural
knowledge, restoring their languages
that it's really encouraging.
Yes?
[ Inaudible Audience Question ]
Well, so the question is
can language communities
with just a couple speakers left,
what resources or recourse
they have.
Breath of Life is very much geared
towards assisting those communities.
Also, community research program has
already worked with the [inaudible]
in California, and with
the [inaudible] language
out of the Warm Springs
Confederated Tribes of Oregon.
And the [inaudible] no longer
have first language speakers.
So, they're rebuilding
a speaker base.
For [inaudible], actually they
don't have first language speakers
any more.
But the process is the
same, they come here,
they look at the materials,
they go back.
There's always someone in the
community, or a group or people
in the community who are
dedicated to learning the language
and becoming second-language
speakers.
And you know, the master
apprentice program is a model
that is often implemented when you
have just a couple of speakers.
You have a couple of speakers and
you know someone pairs up with one
of them and now you have an
exchange of linguistic knowledge
and you know people who can
hold on to that language even
if these two last speakers
pass away.
I mean it's a less
than ideal situation.
But Breath of Life is precisely
named Breath of Life because it's
so heavily focused on
those kinds of situation.
Yes?
[ Inaudible Audience Question ]
Yes. So, the question is
what interaction have I had
with the diaspora community
of [inaudible] in Los Angeles.
I dedicated my dissertation to the
study of the diaspora community
and the relationship between them
and the home community and how
that affected language vitality.
And I carried out a couple
of extra field research trips
to the LA area after
my dissertation.
Much to my regret,
it's the one project
that has fallen beyond my bandwidth.
And it's not something I've
been able to follow up with.
So, I've done it in
a number of ways.
I've maintained my contact
in a number of ways.
So, for example, the young
woman in the checkered shirt,
kind of on your right of the
photography, she is a member
of the [inaudible] community
in the Los Angeles area.
She is one of very, very few people
in the community within the US
or [inaudible] that have
gotten an undergraduate degree.
She got it in biology.
And when I met her during one of
my field research visits to LA,
she told me that she was
interested in cultural elements.
Recovery of cultural knowledge,
considering in the
diasporic context.
And we know one thing led to another
and when I put together
this project.
I told her listen,
this is an example
of how you can bring your biology
background and your interest
in culture and do something
very meaningful
for many different stakeholders.
And so, I was able to
fund a trip for her
to come to the project from LA.
So, it's not something I've
been able to follow up on.
But, for example, I have it in
my radar may be a year from now
to replicate this project in
three or four other communities.
Zapotec communities in Mexico.
And it's in my radar to keep
track of this young woman.
Because the community
[inaudible] is one of the places
where I would want
to do the research.
And she could be the
person leading that effort.
So, again it's not something that's
going to happen like this, but yes,
there's always a way to
you know pull them in.
Yes?
[ Inaudible Audience Question ]
Yes, absolutely.
They have to.
Sometimes we have invited
linguists whose research is not
in that language family.
But, on the condition that
they need to get up to speed
on the literature and so on.
So yes, absolutely that
is a critical element
of the selection of the linguist.
And the linguist goes through
a competitive process too.
This year, God, I mean we're
going to need 15 linguists.
And we've got about 35 applications.
So, it's just as competitive
on that side.
Which is great.
[ Inaudible Audience Comment ]
Yeah. Like I wouldn't be
able to help someone working
on an Algonquin language.
But there might be, I'm hoping.
There might be a Zapotec
researcher coming this year.
She happens to be at UMass Amherst.
And we happen to have a huge
collection of untapped materials
from [inaudible], which is her town.
So, all of us, and you
know she speaks English
and so she can be part of this.
So, hopefully it will work out.
[ Inaudible Audience Question ]
How do you turn it around?
So, the question is how do you turn
around, you know attitudes that are,
yeah, apathy or what's the word.
Yes, indifference, or helpless ness,
yeah I think that's a big issue.
And also, you know
there's other things,
a lot of discrimination
involved and so on.
So, language attitude
really is a critical factor.
I mean after all it is language
attitudes and similar types
of displays of tolerance
or intolerance
that have driven these
languages to the state
of affairs that we have now.
Changing them, as we know, social
change is a very long-term project.
So, awareness raising
is really important.
Raising awareness about
the value of diversity.
Because we've been taught since the
1800s when nations were being built
around the model of one nation, one
language, that that's the only way
to sustain you know
the unity of a nation.
And you know with that comes a lot
of educational practices grounded
on the notion that people;
children can only learn one language
and if they learn two or
more, they'll be delayed.
They'll go crazy, etcetera.
So, now, we're in a different
situation where we have
to research backed data to show
that a child not only can earn more
than a language, but that the child
will develop certain abilities
beyond the levels that a monolingual
child will be able to develop them.
And these are abilities
like executive function.
The ability to focus on
one thing despite the fact
that we might have a lot
of stimuli around you.
That is much more developed
in a bilingual child
than in a monolingual child.
So, we can start pushing that out
and I think linguists are doing
a decent job in doing that.
It's just that perhaps there isn't a
very good centralized way to do it.
Although UNESCO has
been trying to do so.
That's why the Mother Tongue
International Day exists.
To just raise awareness
internationally about the fact
that there are 7000 languages.
They all are important for a reason
or another, and the reasons go
of the spectrum of human
rights to it's critical
for the advancement of science.
And you know so, again, I think
that there are a lot of movements,
perhaps not as widespread
as we would want them.
And certainly, revitalization
cannot wait for all
of these changes to happen.
They actually have to happen at
the same time and for example
within the linguistics discipline
seeing communities engage
with the revitalization of their
language just has pulled the entire
discipline along.
And there's still people
who are armchair linguists
who are not going to get involved.
But an entire generation
of linguists has emerged
that is dedicated to documenting
these languages and working
in a collaborative way
with these communities.
So again, I think these are all
things that are going to have
to happen at the same time.
I mean just to give
an example, in Mexico,
the last 10 years have
been critical.
Mexico has very progressive
legislation
in support of indigenous languages.
The practice is a whole other issue.
But because that legislation exists,
an organization that is a law based,
a legal consultancy, not-for-profit
legal consultancy grounded
on the observance of linguistic
rights has emerged in Oaxaca
that has entirely transformed
the scene in Oaxaca.
They work with judges to educate
them, and so on and so forth.
I mean it's work that is very
removed from what we're doing
in Recovering Voices,
because we can't do it all.
We're not going to go
and save the world.
But everybody is having to do
you know what they know how to do
and apply it to supporting
the same goal.
Any other questions?
[ Inaudible Audience Question ]
Yeah, very good question.
So, the question is how many
languages can we support
with the collections that we have
at the National Anthropological
Archives.
We can very safely say that
we probably have something
from every single language
that has been spoken
in the United States
since the 1800s.
How much do we have is
a different question?
We have very vast collections of
Algonquin languages, for example.
There's a language that
was spoken in California
that no longer has speakers and
that was very poorly documented.
The language is [inaudible] and
in 2011 we hosted a researcher
from the [inaudible] community.
And at first when I saw what we
had I was like well it's not a lot.
I don't think that she's going to be
able to do much with this material.
But then I learned
about the situation
and this person was actually
scouting the world for documentation
on [inaudible], which meant that
her coming to see these materials
and this was before we had a
more robust digitization element
as we do now.
But it made a lot of sense for her
to come even though this was
not a massive collection.
But the other thing is that that's
why we partner with the Library
of Congress and NMAI,
because sometimes we might have
a little bit and they have a ton.
So, yeah. So, right now, precisely
right now, we're in the process
of looking at the collection.
So, we've already done
our survey based on the 65
or 70 people who've
applied we've already looked
at our collections
to determine what we.
And there were a few
cases where I noted
that we didn't have a
very robust collection.
And so now our program
assistant is going to look
at what these languages and what
library of Congress and NMAI have
for these languages because that
might change the picture entirely.
Yeah. Yeah.
And the thing is exchanging
resources and making all
of these resources, not just
the NAA, but the resources
in the three institutions available.
Well, thank you for
the great questions.
[ Applause ]
>> GUHA SHANKAR: So, thank
you so much Gabrielle,
that was an amazing presentation.
Thank you all for coming and
from the prospect of the Library
of Congress, we are very happy and
glad to be part of this enterprise
that you have embarked on and we
look forward to working with you
and give us some food
for thought here
on how our collections might best
serve, you know this enterprise
that we're all in together.
So, thanks again.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us@LOC.com